scheiße von der seite junge [ __ ]
einmaleffekt einmal ja [ __ ] einmal er
sagt ich schlage auf wie nein und es
passiert nichts so dass ich so gerne
revanche
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde connys rage und zwar seine
neue serie wo ich spiele aufgabe hd und
wie die serie schon heiß von swaraj mode
werde ich so ausrasten bzw nicht sehr
rumschreien tauch rumschreien aber auch
eine menge beleidigen weil ich einfach
gerade eine runde gespielt habe und es
hat mich mega aufgeregt dass ich einfach
nicht gewonnen hat und dass ich einfach
so verdammt schlecht in diesem
spielmodus bin deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht ich recorder das ganze jetzt mal
regt mich dabei ein bisschen auf wenn
ihr im zweiten part wollt dann lasst auf
jeden fall die daumen hoch da und
schreibt seine kommentare ob ihr
wirklich ein zweiter partner von haben
wollt weil ich werde euch nicht werden
beleidigungs rate von 3 beleidigungen
pro millisekunde machen und das wird
heftig sein und ich schreibe hier die
ohren voll trainiert schon unglaublich
laut deswegen wenn ihr noch mehr davon
wollt dann gebt einfach den daumen hoch
wenn wir 5000 regen dieser schafft oder
eine million oder irgendwann kommt
vielleicht noch mal was und mein gott
ich das schon wieder auf wie alle ist so
2-sieg um bis das spiel losgeht und ich
laufe los und tara die map ist terminal
und roadster ist der erste kino ich
treffe mich selbst ich komm rein ich
sterbe genauer geil dass der nächste
stop so dass der nächste geil da hinten
steht auch noch eine der steht jetzt
auch so zählt natürlich den schneeball
weil mit dem schneeball wie gesagt phd
punkt irgend einen scheißdreck keine
ahnung der service auf jeden fall geil
die leute sind geil besser als halb so
schneeball tod bahn so schnell aus
dingsda er wechselt einfach schneller
als ich läuft bei ihm alter nein nein
nein
schnebel tod so freaks auch tot so
double luca fig die szene sondern du
kriegst mich nicht so jungem alter es
regt mich auf ich schaffe es nicht
einfach mal drei vier hintereinander ich
bin ich bin vierter warum bin ich nur
vierter hinter konzernleiter krieg
direkten stemann interesse scheiße
sonnig vom er kommt er kommt oft noch
weglaufen
ich habe ein schuss gehört ich habe
schon gehört
der fall liegt am boden ich werde
getroffen genau you've read stirbt
walter fried halt dein maul stirb du
verdammter penalty schmeißt ihnen stehen
wir einfach das arschloch rein junge so
schneeball stirb du [ __ ]
ja ich habe schon wieder geil nein nein
frodo tod so babbel so dahin ist der
nächste schneeball nein tot
auch tote von mir so dann kommt der
nächste sieht schon mal den schuss da
kommt der fall erst der fall
und er ist auch der krieg informieren
jetzt kriegt an des läster nächste der
schwank auf seinen bogen jetzt schon das
messer gezückt 5 killzone jungs bei mir
läuft jetzt nein
timo kraft erhalten ein perfektes wohl
kräftig schlag in tausend mal es
passiert einfach nichts
auch tot warum warum ich bin wieso bin
ich ich habe eine karte von 12 zu acht
das geht fit das geht fit das muss ich
echt sagen und bat sein dass hinter mir
eine kallas hinter mir egal
okay gut großbauern welche da hinten da
hinten den staub ich mir jetzt egal wer
es ist er wird sterben
egal mit was du stirbst so tot so pucher
kommt der nächste schnee ball steht
nicht okay so gut gut gut leben wieder
aufladen hinter dem dings verstecken
münster stecken ich versuche ich
versuche warum es braucht immer drin in
mir drin
ich bin so an die hügelige weiß nicht
wie ich will nen scheiß egal wie das
ausgesprochen
junge du brauchst du gar nicht so
spannend schneeball bestimmt nicht
schluss foto stier wir für einen
schneeball wir viel einfacher neben
genau trifft mich
guido hatten heck oder in der trift
wenig einfach immer immer so jungs ich
bin jetzt aus einer von diesen pussy
spielern ich stell mich jetzt hier und
wartet bis die rheiner spot den
denn demnächst an weil ich scheiße warum
mache ich das nicht weil ich nicht
behindert bin bin ich bin nein wenn ich
nicht freaks du da man warum kannst du
diese
ich glaube du ein schales umgefällt
ich laufe durch die durch und weg von
seinem fall getroffenen anderen bestimmt
weil ich krieg hier noch die krise okay
beide treffen nicht mit dem schneeball
unternehmen dann natürlich ich mache das
übrigens alles mit ihr ding sind mit
zahlen tippen also 23 drücken und nicht
mit dem zahlen rat dann mit dem mausrad
stirb so hinter mir tausendprozentig
eine sache das sind damit eine auch tot
so dreyer
und warum bin ich so schlecht warum bin
ich denn so schlecht auch tot
ich meine ich hab ne kd die geht
unglaublich für die geht unglaublich fit
scheiße von der seite junge fig dein
maul [ __ ] einmaleffekt einmal er sollte
schlag auf ihn ein und es passiert
nichts so natürlich eine revanche
ich finde da ich habe dreimal du
kassierst jetzt warum warum ich nehme
diese scheiß komplex und es passiert
jungs jetzt will ich zu positiv ich
schieße vor mich und ich treffe mich
selber warum ich krieg dich siegte krise
hier trotz sich schon auf meinem
bildschirm
junge junge junge auch tod so jetzt
kommt jetzt kommt rage konnte jetzt
kommt rage coni vor ich war gerade
joggen da habe ich mich zum power
ausgefertigt plan maul halten tot
jetzt hab ich auch noch nie so jung sexy
oder war das 36
egal wer wieder hoch da schon der
nächste der schlägt hier nur der schnitt
mit messer herum richtiger kontrast ist
das alter richtiger konkreter con moto
freaks tot
er steht in der wand drin er steht in
der wanderin bei ihm läuft auf jeden
fall entsteht einfach eine wanderin
tillich war nicht das ist nicht einfach
hin zu gold
er darf das und der steht ja einfach und
wartet wie es vorhin gesagt habe es gibt
spaß die stehen einfach und warten und
er ist von spaß dem stetter und wertet
freaks ist auch tot aber ich auch und
zwar von tricks waren gegenseitiger gilt
das akzeptiert ja noch für halbwegs ja
er steht am fenster und erwartet aber
der krieg ist man schön schnee war deine
fresse der penner kriegs teile dein maul
so double und ist kommt der teufel das
kommt der titel kommt der portals kommt
kein kurt aber idee dass der isn triple
dessen und doppel im chat egal
conny ist auf dem vierten platz bei ihm
läuft auf jeden fall 33 zu 24 wenn man
mit rage dabei ist dann ist dieses spiel
echt geil
so und jetzt und ich habe ihn noch in
mit den tod reißen können hat er das war
geil so leute jetzt kommt kommt der
trafic salam erwartet er wartet der
wartet conny wartet hier drüber jump zum
flugzeug
zum schluss seiner komplett 36 und da
ist es einfach tot
so leute jetzt kommt ihr der fall der
fall kommt und er ist explodiert er es
tot
und das war ein bug ein double
wannigmann kill
würde die lustig auch wann gegenwärtiger
kill nee ich hab nämlich wieder gar kein
getötet ich weiß es nicht warum die
hohen stocks menge kleine kids bekommen
vielleicht am sef verfickte stachel im
fleisch auch drin aber ich habe keine
ahnung ich will auch keine ahnung haben
es ist einfach nur packe ich verstehe es
nicht wo bin ich überhaupt ohne scheiß
man wo bin ich jetzt verlauf ich mich
auch noch genau ich bin ja nicht im
terminal bereich e-commerce schneeball
da kriegst du eine fresse du rohren
schmuck so jetzt kommt hier nämlich
conny in rage frodo ist der nächste so
auf tour de france jetzt geht hier
nämlich direkt auf dem boden sieht das
der folie oder wieder neues bond zugtier
natürlich direkt den bogen oder ist der
foto auch schon wieder tot stellen dass
der core gamer daran kommt da hinten
kommt auch direkt die nächsten kommen da
die nächsten konter die nächsten ich
stehe natürlich mitten in der map jetzt
muss er natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen
kommt von links welche form von rechts
weg ich habe keine ahnung burgen ist
zeugnis gezückt kommt mir keiner hier in
die quere
dann wird er definitiv sterben an den
stacheln eines bogens und die runde ist
vorbei leute das war die erste folge
kommt rage mein herz ist am kochen wie
sonstwas talk talk talk talk talk also
ich bin echt froh wenn man mit rachel
weisz gemacht sodass gleich viel mehr
spaß zu spielen da ist noch viel mehr
drin
wenn ihr mehr conny stage haben wollt
dann schafft einfach 5000 daumen hoch
und schreibt alle mal es könnt ihr dann
in die kommentare schreiben
ich bin da day schreibt einfach rage in
die kommentare rage oder mehrere mehr
rage das schreibt er in die kommentare
von 5.000 daumen hoch da kommt eventuell
mehr college und ich werde mich
versuchen das öfter hochzuladen
weil ich habe einfach bock darauf
manchmal wenn ich einfach adrenalin pur
ab da muss jetzt einfach immer draußen
lassen sie mich das an dieser serie